it's really intimate that receptor in
the nose
that's detecting what's out there in
order to make its report to the brain
actually binds to the molecule grabs
onto it
so for a moment a split second that's
right that
that thing that you're smelling is part
of you
what have you spent the last few years
researching
smell and more particularly smells so
uh things in the world that we encounter
and
experience every day that we
generally don't pay a lot of attention
to and that turn out to be
really really well at least interesting
enough to me to spend 10 years on it
uh i mean interesting enough to write
everyone who's watching on youtube is
going to be able to see the size of this
tome
here i also have to admit i ruptured my
achilles a couple of months ago
and this is the only book that was high
enough to work as a step
for when i also needed to do some of my
exercises
um so also it's got it's got multiple
uses let's let's start then let's define
our terms
what is a smell
so a smell is a perception
that we human beings have that's
actually generated in our brains
but it is stimulated by molecules in the
world
little bits of the things around us
so in that sense smell is uh the most
direct
contact we have with the world because
sight is a matter of you know reflected
light waves
and hearing is pressure waves in the air
it's smell that actually gives us
information about the particular things
themselves
and we detect them by noticing molecules
of theirs that are small enough
to escape those things and fly through
the air
so that we can inhale them and when we
inhale them
they interact with a receptor in the
nose
the receptor then reports that it's
received something
from the outside world to the brain and
then
the brain deals with that it it turns
that information
into a perception but not just based on
that
one thing alone it's based on uh all the
other information it's getting at the
same time
and our database of experience and then
it gives us a
an interpretation of what it is that
we've encountered
where does a smell manifest because a
touch manifests
where where on my body is affecting the
object the taste manifests on my tongue
how does a smell make the sensation of a
smell
that's a great question and uh it turns
out that because the brain is trying to
integrate all this different information
it's kind of leading us
to how should we say
uh ascribe the smell to the thing
something around us you know it we're
detecting it
in our nose right here but we don't
generally think of
smells as i don't feel it in my nose
yeah
yeah yeah and it's really interesting
what happens when we eat something
because
uh smell is a very important aspect of
flavor really the dominant aspect of
the flavors of foods and what's
happening when we detect
the smell from food is that or we could
call it aroma
nicer nicer term for foods
when we have something in our mouth when
we
exhale air passes from the mouth
through the nose out and it's
that root that gives us the impression
of what's in our mouth
and it turns out that you know when we
think about the flavor of food we think
of
the flavor being in our mouth uh
because that's where the food is but in
fact the smell is being detected up here
so the brain kind of uh relocates it to
the place where the
the action is and uh that's why we think
that the
the smell is there rather than there can
you impact
the taste of something by affecting your
breathing technique then
yes absolutely um and
uh it i mean lots of different things to
say about that but
you know one of them is simply um
how how much of those molecules
are introduced into your nose and that
has to do with
how close you are to the thing um how
deeply
you breathe in how often you breathe in
you know sniffing is a way of you know
picking something up you're
you're you know there's something out
there but you're not quite sure what it
is so you're sniffing it out
that sniffing is repeated um
intakes of those molecules to give our
receptors and brain
another chance to figure out what it is
i always noticed when
everyone will know this you put your
hand down toward a dog and it it smells
your hand but it does it in a sort of a
it does that very quick in and out i'm
going to guess that that's what the dogs
are trying to do
what's the difference when smelling
something between one long
inhale and multiple very short inhales
uh well with with one long one uh
what's going to happen likely is that
your receptors will not have time to
reset
you know if you keep breathing in the
same thing constantly
uh your brain will actually pay less
attention to it because it kind of
becomes kind of part of the
the background you know the wallpaper of
your experience
whereas if you breathe in and out the
the
sensation is going on and off and your
brain
is able better to pay attention to that
and perhaps identify what it is that's
uh that's doing it and by the way
animals sniffs
are really really short you know they're
fractions of a second
um i've i've you know tried to time
myself i
i can't do that i would pay good money
to watch that video of you trying to
time yours your sniffs
but it's uh it's fun you know it's it's
uh
a sense that we kind of take for granted
that we don't really um exercise
and you know it's it's really easy to do
you can do it just
sitting right here talking to each other
i mean one of the things that i write
about
in the book is the smell of a
laptop you know if you stick your nose
down next to the keys
and inhale you'll get the smell of the
uh the circuit boards in there which are
made of particular molecules that are
given off and
so it has a very particular smell uh so
it's it's something that
that's one of the reasons i loved the
last 10 years even though it was
kind of a long haul is that there's just
so much out there to pay attention to
that we generally don't
one of the things that i really enjoyed
that you said at the beginning was about
how it's one of our most direct senses
and you're correct like touch it smell
is kind of like
touch if the thing you were touching
turned into a volatile and went inside
of you
yes little bits of the thing that you're
touching
getting in you and then you noticing it
in a completely different way
yeah and in fact uh it's it's really
intimate um
so that receptor in the nose that's
detecting what's out there
in order to make its report to the brain
actually binds
to the molecule grabs onto it so for a
moment
uh a split second that's right that
that thing that you're smelling is part
of you and
it's very dangerous when i think of some
of the smells that have entered my nose
i don't know if i want to be a part of
them
exactly exactly it it's uh
you know it explains perfectly why it is
when something doesn't smell
so good we hold our nose we don't we
don't allow ourselves to take it in
because we have this kind of sense that
it's becoming too too close to our
insides why can we detect smells
uh we can detect smells mainly because
our uh animal ancestors uh
are able to do that and uh have been
able to do that from the earliest
uh forms of life on earth and that's
because it's really important for
living things to know what's around them
uh in order to know
you know what direction food might be
what direction
something dangerous might be and so
uh chemical sensors and that's what uh
the sense of smell is a chemical sense
uh are is probably the earliest sense
that
uh the living things had no way even
before eyesight
oh uh eyes are really complicated
structures you know bacteria have
chemical senses um
things that we uh think of as being
really primitive and not really
uh doing anything except you know going
blindly through
through the world hoping to luck out on
finding some
some food no they they have senses uh
systems for detecting molecules and then
changing their behavior in order to take
advantage of that information
and that would be more analogous to
smell than it would be to any other
sense
that's right that's right because it is
again latching on to
a molecule taste is also a chemical
sense
um and uh so you could say that
uh these early forms would be a
combination of taste and smell
i was looking at uh i can't remember
what i was learning about e coli
bacteria living in the gut
and basically they can spin one way and
it makes them
go in a circle or they can spin the
other way and it makes them go straight
and they basically have an if this then
that function which is
if the i think that they might be
looking for
perhaps glucose if the area that they
move to
has more glucose then spin in the
direction that makes them go straight if
it doesn't then spin in the direction
that makes them
the other way it's like such a simple
you know you could write it into a
computer code in
two minutes um but yeah that's utilizing
the
chemical response that's right they have
to have the receptor for glucose to know
that it's out there
exactly don't you so smells are created
by these little volatiles tiny little
particulates of whatever it is that goes
on
and they're made up of something
fundamental
i know there's five basic tastes right
is the same thing true with smell
uh no that's the the thing that makes
smell really special
so it's true that we have these two
chemical senses taste on the tongue and
smell
in the nose taste is limited to about a
dozen
different sensations there are
arguments these days about exactly how
many but at least
sweet sour salty bitter
savory then some scientists would add a
couple of others but
that's that's basically it
smell we have around 400
different receptors which can act um
combinatorially to detect
uh many many different molecules so
thousands upon thousands upon thousands
and again scientists argue about exactly
how many but
it's it's uh way more than we
can detect with taste and um
it's what gives the the
uh gives us the the most particular
information
about the world around us
if smell is so
fine if the the way that we can smell
things
the combinations that we can come out
with so much greater than taste
i would i would guess that most people
if i said you've got to lose one of your
five senses
most people would lose smell and they'd
be upset
but they probably wouldn't care that
much if you lost taste you'd be a bit
more annoyed and then when you get into
like the big three
that would be a real drop off why is it
that smells got such a fine
uh ability to adjust and
this combinatory particular formula
if it's also something that we feel like
we could dispense with quite easily
well it's um yeah it's a
an interesting question and if in fact a
lot of people are facing
that kind of issue these days with kovid
covid
because that's one of the early symptoms
of a coveted infection
is derangement
either loss or just complete mess-up of
smell and or taste and
um you know people respond differently
there are uh people who lose their sense
of taste or
smell for a variety of reasons i myself
lost my sense of smell while i was
writing this book
[Laughter]
which was uh a little disturbing
yeah yes yeah um
so and it it really does depend
on how important it has been to you in
your life up to that point
um and in fact my experience was that
um there was just no pleasure left in
eating you know you would satisfy
the growling stomach but then
that was it you know there was really no
point in spending time
cooking no point in going to a
restaurant and paying good money
because i was just kind of filling this
hunger
that gave me no no satisfaction um
i guess all these sounds are
satisfaction all you've got left is
texture
right is that it uh well taste
also because i didn't lose my sense of
taste so i could still get sweetness and
bitterness but pungency um
uh you know hot pepper is actually a
a touch sensation and
um that is something that
you you can still feel and a lot of
people will
try to compensate for the absence of
these other
sensations by upping that uh
stimulation yeah but uh yeah i would
i personally would just hate to lose
either of them
taste taste or smell either one uh you
might think the taste might be easier to
get rid of because
it's only you know those four or five
different sensations
but people who lose their sense of taste
report the same kind of thing they can
still smell foods
but when they eat them it's the the
brain can no longer make that connection
that those smells are in here
so it's it's more like you know eating
perfume or something like that
it's not satisfying in the in the same
way it's not not
grounded yeah i bet it's not are there
any technologies that are interacting
with smells now are we going to get an
entertainment system that
kicks some smells out when we're
watching a tv program or anything
well actually uh that that idea has been
around for a while
uh smell-o-vision was uh an experiment
back it was always going to be the name
wasn't it anyone that didn't use that
name
was they were losing out that's right
and in fact uh you know there's this uh
american film director john waters who
does
um interesting kind of offbeat movies
and he did one
back in the 1970s that uh involved
a scratch and sniff card so you walked
into the
theater and with your ticket you were
given one of these
cards and then you were cued by the
movie as to when to scratch and sniff
and there were very nice smells and
really disgusting smells on that card
and i actually uh dug that card up
uh like a year ago so maybe 30 years
after
i took it home with me from the movie
showing
and i scratched and sniffed and those
smells were still there
so that's the robust technology
the the newer idea is to use some kind
of digital coding
so that you have a little box next to
your computer
and it releases some combination
of volatile molecules in response to
what
whatever it is you're trying to um uh
synthesize
uh my experience so far
has been that it's it's not really very
effective
the technology's got a way to go i went
on a uh
i want to call it like wings of
flight or something it was disneyland in
la
last year and uh you go on this big ride
and you sort of
up in the air and it's one of those ones
where the screen is moving and you're
pivoting and twisting around with it but
this had
you would be going over the african
planes and they were pumping the smell
of grass in
and you were flying over the top of the
ocean and they were pumping the smell of
sea spray in
and that was that was pretty cool it was
this sort of thing that stuck in my
memory
because i think it's so rare that we get
at least from an
entertainment perspective it's so rare
that we have our smell manipulated right
that's right uh people have done uh uh
operas uh smells smelly operas
yeah yeah exactly that doesn't offer my
smell
but the problem with with things like
operas and plays and
concerts things like that in general is
that you're sitting
in a seat which is stationary and they
have to blow the
the smells at you in in this you know
cavernous
uh room and then get them out of there
in time for the next one and the smells
don't do that really easily you know the
molecules kind of hang around and so
you really have to design uh
an amusement park uh a thing like that
with those things in mind what are some
of the tricks that we can play on our
physiology with smells can we
use them to affect us positively you
know i've seen
sleep sprays that you spray on your
pillow before you go to bed and there's
awakeness this and you know caffeine in
a
in a smelly bottle that like is there
any efficacy to these and are there any
other things that we can do to sort of
utilize
smells to to help us
well there are uh studies that
have shown that particular smells in
particular cultures
can have uh physiological effects
generally speaking either relaxing
or stimulating um you know it doesn't
really get any more fine-grained than
that
and it and it is culture dependent so
it's kind of what you associate those
smells with
apparently i mean this it's not an easy
thing to study in a
in a systematic way but generally
speaking it seems that
lavender is a
relaxing smell for most people
and citrus smells are stimulating
[Music]
which is kind of interesting because
they actually share
some components
you know smells are we we think of the
smell of lavender or the smell of a
lemon
as being some unitary thing like
molecules of lemon molecules of lavender
uh but in fact uh what these
volatiles are are their bouquets
they come at us in large numbers
and what our brain does is register the
the overall bouquet
and then interpret that and so it's more
like a chord
in music uh rather than particular notes
we're
sensing the the whole thing and
uh it turns out that lavender and uh
citrus share notes so why they should
have divergent
uh effects on people is an interesting
question
um it's fascinating it's fascinating
that
so much of what a smell means to us
is based on our history with it our
interpretation of it
even when we think about what smells
nice and what smells bad like if you
think sort of
rotting meat at one end and fresh grass
at the other there's a reason for that
right that it's become
embedded in us our evolutionary
ancestors would have found it
advantageous to know that that meat is
off and this grass
grass is fresh and therefore the effect
that it has on us and then obviously
you can have that uh sort of more
epigenetically within your lifetime
where you're thinking okay i i remember
mum used to put lavender on my pillow
when i was sick as a kid therefore i
really like lavender i love
alba soil like because that was the
thing that i had on the radiator when i
was ill so i've
got it on the radiator now and i'm still
32 years old a massive child
um but yeah it's fascinating that the
smell itself kind of
is just a thing and we then run forward
with that
a lot further we interpret it it becomes
this subjective very narrative
personified interpretation of what that
means
exactly um and it's kind of interesting
you know
it it does seem to make sense
evolutionarily that we know the
difference between
rotting meat and and
fresh fruit for example on the other
hand it also turns out that
in human development there are several
years
in kind of toddler the toddler era
where we human beings are totally
neutral
when it comes to uh to smells or
or much more neutral than adults are and
you know you can see this with little
children who are
sticking their hands into things that
aren't such a good thing to
stick our hands in because they don't
have the same
revulsion automatic revulsion that
adults do
and it's it's unclear you know why this
is exactly i mean it's important for
developing animals to you know have a
broad enough
um tolerance for things that they can
actually
feed themselves and and thrive
um on the other hand it's also important
to be able to distinguish among
uh poisonous things and not so poisonous
things
so why it is that there's this window of
um
uh flexibility uh
why it is there's this window of
flexibility is is still unclear
yeah that is interesting what are some
of the most unique smells
that you experienced ah
that's uh that's a tough one um
i i really didn't know much and
perfume world before i started writing
about uh
smells you know food and drink has been
my thing for decades
this was kind of out of that um but uh
that just ended up becoming really
fascinating to me
and there are particular incense woods
that are
also used in perfumery that are just
uh intoxicating you know if you um
uh i i went to japan a few years ago
and was indoctrinated in this practice
they have
called the english translation is
incense
listening so rather than just lighting a
stick in your room and
and just kind of floating on that you
actually
uh sit down and focus on a particular
little bit of incense wood and it smells
and think about it and then take another
little bit
of a different wood and think about it
really pay attention to what the
qualities are so it's like
you know learning to taste wine or
something like that and
um a couple of those woods were just you
know
they they had to pull me away from the
table they were just so so beautiful
and um kind of hard to describe because
they're um
you know it's uh like trying to describe
a lemon you know a lemon is
lemony and these incense woods just had
this
character that that was something i had
never experienced before and it was just
really
rich and just kept kept you wanting to
smell
more because there seemed to be layer on
layer on layer
can you remember the name of them if
people want to try and buy them online
oh yeah uh it's the the one i
particularly love has several different
names so it's
one is agarwood agar
wood uh it's sometimes also known as
ood which is oud
uh and uh another couple names
that are escaping me at the moment but
but either of those will
will get you there and it's it's really
interesting stuff it's um
it's produced by uh a
southeast asian tree that has become
infected by a fungus
and in response to that infection it
generates this resin
to defend itself and it's that resin
that gives it that that amazing aroma
it's so crazy how the downstream effects
of things uh
and end up to this combination but as
you say if we've got 400 different
dials on the mixing desk that we can
play around with and
each combination of those comes out
differently it's not surprising that you
might get odd results from something
that you were
you wouldn't have thought of what animal
smells did you look at
ah as many as i could think of
and find so actually in the in the
incense and perfume world that again was
something that came as a surprise to me
we might think that animal smells are
generally
not that pleasant compared to
woods and flowers and fruits and things
like that
but it turns out that animal materials
are really important in
perfumery and they're
among the most valuable ingredients
there are for perfumery
one of them uh the the
one that i think has the most
interesting backstory is ambergris
or ambergri so
this is uh a material that comes from
the uh lower digestive tract
of the sperm whale
i want to know who the first guy is that
was
that thought that sperm whale that we
just caught over there anyone has anyone
sniffed it to lower digestive tract
recently because
i'm certain i'm absolutely certain boys
if we bottle that we've got a million
pound business there well we do have
uh over here this this uh classic novel
moby dick about the whaling industry
there's a lot about ambergris in
in moby dick uh but it wouldn't have
been
quite the scenario you propose because
what would happen is that the
the whales swimming in the ocean would
die
their carcasses would would come apart
and
these bits would end up being washed up
on the beach
uh or on the shore all over all around
the world and in fact this is still the
way that most ambergris
is found is just by chance people
walking on the beach
and coming across a lump which looks
like
nothing in particular which again is
it's kind of hard to describe but it's
not fishy
the way you would expect it's flowery
and yeah just
kind of transcendent smelling but it
came from the lower digestive system
of a sperm whale what other animal stuff
did you look at
uh well let's see i uh ask the question
why does
uh excrement smell the way it does
and what information might that give us
about
what's going on and uh
that turns out to be at least if you're
willing to
think about things like that pretty
interesting because
you know we've discovered in the last 10
years that we have this microbiome
uh in our guts that are whose
uh number of cells uh outnumber
human cells in our own body and uh
the the this collection of microbes has
a tremendous effect on
our health on our digestion
on just all aspects of our lives pretty
much
and it turns out that uh because
excrement is coming from their home
uh it carries the the signatures
of the microbes that are in there and
what it is they're up to
and so there are particular uh how shall
we say
uh particular excremental bouquets
that uh indicate that things are working
pretty well
and others that indicate that um
that there are bacteria and they're
making things that are not
as good for us as as the other microbes
so the closer that that smell comes to
the smell
of um uh newborn babies
poop uh the better
and the more the the more sulfurous and
just offensive it is the more it
indicates that
uh in fact we're uh
feeding the the bacteria that tend not
to be
good for us and so we might want to
switch to
a diet that gives us something more like
what the
what the baby gives us switching back
to that our smells or what how we
interpret smells
are narrative personifications they're
also
evolutionary indicators of what's going
on
presumably that's adaptive that we
wouldn't have been disgusted
or concerned or felt made to feel sick
by excrement potentially ours which
didn't have this stuff in because
there's no real difference it's not like
one smell is worse
objectively and one smell is better
objectively it's how we interpret those
right and
the signal that that gives off
exactly yeah and in fact there are uh
examples that i give in the book of
creatures
that in fact uh consume excrement
and some of them consume their own so
the gorilla
which is a close relative of ours
um has been observed many many times uh
catching the excrement as it comes out
and bringing it up and smelling it and
enjoying it and then
having some so
i wonder how many people opened this
podcast today
and thought that they would hear the
word excremental bouquet
and then imagine imagine a huge gorilla
uh sniffing its own poop yeah yeah
well this is this is the world that you
have been in for the last decade harold
so
who are we to complain about it what
about plants what did you learn about
the smells that plants give off
well so if you think about the the
general contrast between animal smells
and plant smells
animal smells we generally find not so
pleasant
plant smells we generally find very
pleasant
flowers for example and fruits and
you mentioned the smell of freshly cut
grass
all very very pleasant and it turns out
that
one of the main differences between
plants and animals is that the smells of
animals are essentially the smells
of the breakdown of our
tissues either naturally
because metabolism involves breakdown as
well as building things up
and because the microbes are living off
of us and so
uh their waste products are also ours
um in the case of plants most of the
smells are actually
created they're they're not breakdown
products they're
they're created by the plants
synthesized by the plants for very
specific purposes
and they're larger molecules they're
they're not the
the small ones that make um animal
smells
uh less pleasant they're large
complicated molecules and there does
seem to be evidence that
um the larger and more complicated a
molecule
is the more likely we are to find it
pleasant
and that kind of makes sense because it
indicates not
decay not breakdown
but in fact something being created
something being synthesized and so
a potential source of food for us
so uh plants make thousands upon
thousands of different
uh molecules that we find pleasant
the the interesting thing uh uh
kind of evolutionarily is that those
smells are there
not to attract animals for the most part
but to repel them
not to attract other living creatures
but to
ward them off they're they're a form of
chemical warfare
and that's because unlike animals plants
are stuck in one place
they can't run away so they have to do
something to discourage
animals that can move around from from
chomping on them
and many of the things that we enjoy and
herbs and spices
and even flowers are there to repel
animals and and prevent them from uh
consuming the plant it feels like we
have quite an emotional attachment to a
lot of different smells but we don't
have that
necessarily with some of our other
senses specifically not with sight
or probably quite as much with sound i
wonder how different people would live
their lives
if i've been a big champion of people
trying to spend as much time in nature
as possible
reconnect with the grandeur of the
cosmos by looking up at the night sky
and making yourself feel insignificant
and
things like that but the
detachment from the the narrative if we
were able to smell
the smell of the night sky the effect
that that has through our eyes
i feel like that would be much more
pungent i feel like it would be a very
very strong
sensation do you get what i mean that
it's much more
what is good for us in terms of what we
view and what is good for us in terms of
what we smell
are actually much more messy on the uh
on site despite the fact that of 14
million sand cells we have in our body
11 million of them are discriminated
towards vision
i just think it's really interesting it
would be an interesting world in which
we attach
that same narrative perhaps and the same
level of
emotion uh and buy-in to
sight and the things that we saw
yeah so
a couple of things are going on one is
that um
the way the brain is wired the sense of
smell
goes much more directly to the emotional
centers of the brain
than the other senses do and that may
have to do with the fact that
the chemical senses are as primitive as
they are
and therefore we're kind of there in the
brain
um long before we had good vision
or hearing yeah yeah and so
they they go much more directly to the
parts of the brain that would make that
kind of
um impression upon us the other thing is
that
and i haven't seen scientists talk about
this but i think it's important
uh with vision work it's kind of on
all the time right we're we're
taking in uh visual information
constantly unless we sleep or something
like that
whereas with the sense of smell it's
much easier
even though we're breathing regularly
it's much easier to ignore it
you know i mean we're sitting now
talking with each other
i don't have a particular sense for the
smells around me at the moment because
i've kind of adapted to this room
its brain has kind of tuned them out
because it's a constant
whereas my vision is working because
i'm you know making eye contact with you
and getting information
from uh from the screen so i think
smell is much more episodic and
therefore it's maybe
easier to um uh to anchor
a particular experience in it because
it's
it's not as continuous as vision is
i think that's a really really good
point you talking of
nature and sort of the earth at large
you looked at the smell of
land and waters sort of on mass as well
what did you learn there
well uh in the case of the land
it took me down a rabbit hole i never
expected because
you done in order to ask why the land
smells the way it does you have to
know what the land is and the land is a
really complicated thing
that didn't exist hasn't existed forever
it was created
by plants over the course of
you know eons and eons of time and
the smell of fresh dug soil
which is so evocative so again
refreshing and so on is um
like the smells of plants uh in general
uh a molecule that's generated by
living things in the soil and at the
moment we
actually don't know why that particular
molecule
is created the the dominant smell of the
of fresh soil is a molecule called
geosmin
and it's generated by a handful
of uh bacteria that live in the soil
um we don't quite understand why because
it's not toxic
it's not you know something to kill
other bacteria or
to ward off other creatures
it might be a signal to other bacteria
that you know i'm here
and you know give me some space or
i'm here and come on over so that we can
exchange genetic
material uh it's it's not known
um so uh and then there's the smell of
stones um uh you might have
heard of something called petrichor
which is a
favorite term of people who are uh
interested in perfumes fragrances but
also
just the smells of the world that's
supposedly the smell of rain
on uh stone so you know the
the smell of the sidewalk after a couple
of
hot days and then all of a sudden you
get this burst of aroma
and it turns out that that smell is
actually
the liberation from that surface of all
the stuff that's been flying around in
the air for the last couple of days
so it's really not anything to do with
the stone
which is what the the name suggests it's
more
the smell of that place suddenly
concentrated and and brought up for you
to
inhale so i think it should be called
gaia eichor
not petrichor gaia because it's the
it's the world it's the planet that uh
that we're smelling in that moment
presumably that means that petrichor or
gaia aiko
would be different on rocks in the
middle of the saharan plains as they
would be in new york as they would be
in japan as they would be in wherever
exactly yeah it's it depends completely
on on what's around and
in the case of something like the sahara
you know
uh those volatiles may have been
collecting for hundreds of years
before they're liberated and um i think
there's something to be said for
you know taking samples from a place
like the sahara
and artificially wetting them and
collecting the volatiles that come off
and getting some idea
perhaps of the of what's going
what's been going on what has been
living in that area
uh over the last however long it had
been
since the the previous reign i remember
reading about bloodhounds and the fact
that they can
detect is it like one part in a billion
or one part in a trillion or something
of particular volatiles have we got any
equivalent
with humans is there some humans with
ridiculously overpowered senses of smell
well actually we are able to detect some
things at parts per billion
also um in fact geosmin
is an example of that and there are
several others we are
we can be very sensitive to particular
molecules
and the people who work on
the senses of taste and smell in human
beings
have been at great pains over the last
few decades to
point out that this idea that
bloodhounds are
better than us at smelling is not really
true
um or at least it needs to be uh put
into context because
bloodhounds uh spend their lives right
next to the ground
and uh so they're very good at picking
up things that are going on right next
to the ground
if you give them a bottle of burgundy or
of uh
an english uh sparkling wine and ask
them to you know distinguish one from
another
they're not so good at that but we are
you know professional wine tasters can
taste a sip of something and and narrow
it down to a very particular
year and place and producer and method
of production and all that kind of thing
so we have um
the same basic set of receptors fewer of
them
but the same basic set of receptors as
uh other animals do
we have way more processing power to
make sense of what it is that we're um
smelling and so just to reduce smell
to um you know how sensitive your nose
is to a particular thing
uh just does uh an injustice to the the
amazing powers that humans have to to
make use of that information other smell
connoisseurs out there like sommeliers
of smell let's
smell leas
[Laughter]
not that i'm aware of but i think it's a
great idea i think you may just have
coined a term
fine fine every anyone that wants to use
that you need to pay me money
um another thing that i was really
fascinated by was the fact that you had
like industrial smells in there as well
burning in industry
charcoal stuff like that and obviously
that's something that we probably
wouldn't have been
very accustomed to i i don't imagine a
volcano goes off all that often and that
we get the opportunity
to smell it so that must be a unique
thing to study
well except that you know human beings
uh
well first of all fire has been an
important aspect of
uh life on earth for like half a million
uh
half a billion years you know long
uh once there were enough plants on the
planet to
generate enough oxygen for a continuous
burning
to take place there has been fire which
can be ignited by
lightning and all kinds of natural
things and then when it comes to human
beings
for probably on the order of a million
years
we've been really dependent on fire for
all kinds of things so it's it's
something that
we are uh
even biologically very well
uh acquainted with and uh
and sensitivity to those smells would
have been important even before we
controlled fire because in order to you
know
escape a fire or to know that one
is nearby without being able to see it
we had to be pretty sensitive
to and aware of those particular
molecules
yeah um what do you think i was
considering this yesterday when i was
reading the book
do you ever think back to times in
prehistoric history
and think about what it would have
smelled like so i was reading about how
in the time of the dinosaurs there
weren't actually any plants it was all
sort of
ferns it was this crumpled ground of
ferns and then if you were to go back
further to
single-celled prokaryotic eukaryotic
life it would be very sulfurous right
it must be it would be interesting to be
able to take samples of that and
actually work out what the earth smelled
like the place that we walk but just in
a time that we weren't
yes well so uh in one of the early
chapters of the book i
i tried to do that so i i asked the
question
what was the early earth like and when
did it become
more like what it is now and it really
did depend on
the invention first in microbes and then
plants took it over the invention of
photosynthesis
which generates oxygen before there was
an excess of oxygen in the atmosphere
everything would have smelled sulfurous
it would have been you know hydrogen
sulfide and
and uh uh
[Music]
uh blanking out uh yeah the the methane
thiols and
things that that we immediately
recognize as being
um uh something to to
be careful about now hydrogen sulfide is
important
an important component the main
component and the smell of hard cooked
eggs
so it's not always bad but you know if
that same
eggy smell were magnified by
a hundred fold then you wouldn't be
happy and that's the kind of smell that
comes out of volcanoes and hot springs
and
and so on and that's what the world
in general would have smelled like
before uh
we had enough oxygen in the air to
oxidize those molecules and
get rid of them how has the study of
smell obviously your background is
majority of the
food up until now how has your learnings
from smell
impacted your view of food or are you
cooking in different ways have you
changed up anything to do with the sort
of tastes that you put into your foods
to manipulate this
not really um uh i
i just pay more attention i guess that's
the the way to put it
and you know when something doesn't
smell quite right
instead of just pushing it away and
saying this is not very nice
i actually take more of it to try to
figure out you know what's what's going
on
what what is it that doesn't smell so
nice and
how might it have been created you know
what what
what went wrong in the cooking process
um and and it is true that i i do
probably um cook with more different
ingredients
nowadays than i used to because i've
become interested in
just the diversity of uh aromas that
the different natural materials have and
i do things like um i've i now have
tea bushes in my backyard and i make tea
okay which by the way i reckon
uh recommend to just about anyone
because it turns out that the t bush
even though we think of it as a
you know an asian exotic sort of thing
it's very hardy
and it it can take frosts no problem
and to me it's just the most amazing
uh transformation you pluck a few
young leaves from a tea plant and smell
them
and they smell like green leaves and you
let them sit
for a couple of hours or you just rub
them a little bit
and let them sit for 10 minutes to speed
things up and then smell them
and they're like flowers and it's
you know all you've done is picked them
or rubbed them
it's just an incredible thing that these
these leaves
are engineered to be able to do
and again it's a it's a defensive
reaction there's a problem so let's ramp
up these molecules that help defend us
but we find them delicious uh so that
would
probably to some common predator
of that particular plant would actually
be a little bit disgusting
uh it would be off-putting to a predator
and
it's also many of these molecules in t
in particular
are also signals so there's a signal
from the leaf that has been
damaged to the rest of the plant to say
ramp up your defenses boys because we've
got a problem up here
ah that's really interesting it's also a
signal that it needs a little bit of
milk and two sugars isn't it
um moving moving forward looking to the
future
are we going to see sense scientists
coming up with anything new are there
any sort of exciting areas in the world
of sense science
oh yeah uh on all uh
on all levels so we're getting better
and better
at detecting the volatile molecules that
are out there in the world
in tiny tiny quantities
and identifying them so that we know
what it is that we're smelling and
get some idea of their backstory what it
is that those molecules are doing there
so now you can for example put a little
bubble around a flower in the jungle in
south america
and in an hour or so extract enough of
its aroma
that you can then take it back to a lab
and identify
all those different molecules it's it's
amazing
um and then on the human side we're
learning more and more
every year about the the circuitry
that's involved in our
perception of smells and then our
interpretation
how it is that our brain takes that
information and turns it into
a conscious perception on our part
so it's very exciting times i like it uh
harold's nosedive a field guide to the
word smells will be
in the show notes below any other things
that people should go and check out
any places you want to send them ah
well i have a website and i uh write
occasionally
uh updates and and you know
talk about uh other related things as
well as food and
the connection of all this to food and
cooking so that would be a place to
start
and that what is it balanced food what's
the website
uh haroldmcgee.com haroldmckee.com
that's it
thank you very much for today man i
really appreci really enjoyed it
me too chris thanks so much
[Music]